[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
So thank you very
much for sharing so
generously with our esteemed,
distinguished, dear guest.
It was very-- I learnt a lot
through the back and forth
between you and Professor
Casimir's questions
and comments.
I Thank you for sharing
so much knowledge.
It's just amazing.
And I'm so glad--
thank you, Tom, thank
you, MIT OpenCourseWare,
for recording this.
This is historical.
And it does have
the potential, I
think, to reach out to folks
on both ends of the spectrum,
both the "Lakou" end and
the "Lagrandyab" end,
both the colonized and the
colonizer, in many ways,
in a way that can
enrich all of us.
So thank you for that.
So now we're going to hear
Ti Jan Bosal introduce
this beautiful chapter, a
powerful chapter on the power
and beauty of the
sovereign people.
And then we go around the
room and ask questions.
JEAN CASIMIR: Thank you.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: And discuss.
JEAN CASIMIR: And I'm
really happy to be here,
because I'm in a
real context where
you feel at home, because
everything you have said up
till now, even from
the very beginning,
gives you the sense what
is "decolonial reading,"
"decolonial study," because
it's something that starts
with your personal position.
You must know where you are.
You must be aware
of where you are.
And from that, you see the
world, you know what I mean?
Because in fact, this is what
is your power, the possibility
of seeing the world from your
position, not from the position
they have given you.
You find your position.
You define your position.
And from your position
you are seeing the world.
And something I have written
and in my mind is fundamental,
the use of social sciences,
the raison d'être of social
sciences is to regain--
to give to those who
have been dispossessed,
to re-empower them.
If not, I don't know
why they study--
I am not there to empower
those who are empowered.
I have been disempowered.
And my aim is to study,
to work so I can regain
my position over
myself, over my people,
and for my people
to move forward.
Now, this implies
understanding myself,
understanding my people,
and understanding the other.
And then I move from there.
So the beauty and power
of the sovereign people
is that we come from
a set of individuals,
because capitalism and European
capitalism, modern time
capitalism is based
on the desegregation
of the communities.
You take the communities.
You make of them
naked individuals.
And then you give
them the possibility
of rejoining within
your own norms--
now called the
"syndicate," called
the trade union,
whatever you want,
but after you make of
them naked individuals.
We are taken from Africa, in the
case of Saint-Domingue, Haiti,
at least 24 different nations.
Now they mix them all.
They mix us up in the country.
And we are going to
recreate ourselves.
How do we do that?
First of all, we
create with nothing,
eh, a group, a social
group just to protect us,
because when you reach there
as an enslaved person, now
they are going to beat you,
to-- well, to destroy you, no?
When you finish working, the
few times they give you to rest,
you will find consolation.
You will find affection.
You will find love.
You will find reciprocity.
You will find solidarity.
You give and take.
You will find human relations.
So you will create, you
recreate a social group.
I mean, this social
group you create
is going to have a set of
principles, a set of norms, no?
And these norms are going to
give way to new individuals.
You're going to create a
new individual according
to your own norms, to
your own principles.
And these new
individuals will be power
in front of the other power.
So that gives you
the possibility
of discovering out of nothing.
Now you're going to
imagine another power.
And it is so important that
the one who brought you
in the Caribbean or in
the plantation system
to exploit you is
willing to spend
all his efforts to destroy
you because you are something.
And you're going to be
aware of that something.
For instance, they will
say Vodou or whatever we do
or be whatever it
is is superstition.
If it is superstition,
it is useless.
Let me use it.
It's not doing anything.
[LAUGHTER]
If it has no solution, why
do you make so much effort
to destroy it?
I mean-- so therefore you
are acknowledging that, no?
Another element that
is important also--
granted, you want me to do that,
I don't do it, you beat me up.
You can even kill
me so I can do it.
But I never see you
killing a donkey
because it doesn't
want to drink water,
because you know the
donkey is an animal.
I mean, so they know--
but me you're going to
beat me until I'm dead.
Therefore, you acknowledge
that I'm equal to you.
If I was not equal
to you, you would not
beat me until I am dead.
You would do like the donkey.
I'd let you beat me [INAUDIBLE].
No, you beat me, because
you know I have a will.
And this will escapes to you--
escapes you.
And this is my power.
OK, with that power in
front of you, might--
because you really
have a might--
I am going now to
create myself, a being,
my sovereignty with nothing.
I'm going to recreate
a new society.
That is the beauty of it.
And this is what we
have to be aware of.
Now, it is not
that I feel strong.
No, no, no, I'm going to create
a whole set of institutions.
You see what I mean?
A language, a
religion, villages,
a set of institutions that I
create to take care of myself
and to reproduce myself and
also to have accountability
for the members of the group.
You see what I mean?
So I create another universe
in front of your universe, no?
And your universe, since you
despise me, cannot see me.
I mean, even when
they see me, they say,
"Oh, these are stupid
things niggers are doing,"
you see what I mean?
Even when they see,
they cannot adjust.
So therefore,
myself, to survive,
I first learn what
you have in mind.
And I, in group--
no, I'm going to
imagine how to bypass
what you have in mind to
the small possibility.
Sometimes I can't.
Sometime I can.
But I will never lose the
opportunity of doing that.
This is-- therefore, some
people coming down here
or brought down here
against their will
after much suffering,
because you do not
leave Africa as a tourist,
no, you are beaten.
And you have to walk sometime
hundreds and hundreds of miles.
They put you in circumstances
you have never imagined.
They put you on the boat,
et cetera, et cetera.
You come here.
And when you come here, now
they start humiliating you,
doing things that are
beyond imagination, no?
They sell you.
The stamp you, et
cetera, et cetera.
I will not describe
all the things.
But in that, I would
say, infinite poverty
and destruction,
you're going to reborn.
This is the beauty of
the sovereign people.
Now, how do you do that?
I say you create a community.
But the community you created
in the plantation itself--
I mean, while you're
working on the plantation,
you're creating social
groups, in spite
of the intention of the
person to call you Black.
"Black" is a colonial world.
In Africa, you're not Black.
You can be Ashanti.
You can be Negro.
You can be Igbo.
You can be anything but Black,
because everybody is Black.
So Black does not
distinguish one to another.
I mean, so you come here,
and you create a little group
on the plantation.
Now in that group, there
are others who really cannot
survive in the plantation.
They will run away.
And you'll have a set
of bandits and people
stole, living out of stealing
goods, coming in and out,
looking for weapons,
et cetera, et cetera.
They are set of generally
male maroons, no?
Those male maroons and
you are in contact.
And at some point in time,
they will with their ladies
go and create the
free village system.
You see what I mean?
Now, from the people
on the plantation,
the independent
fighters or brigands
or whatever they call them
to the village system,
you have a constant movement
of ideas [INAUDIBLE]..
And this is done through the
language, through the language.
So you have now a whole--
in the plantation system
before independence,
you have a whole movement
of concept, of habits,
of conducts that teach you
the possibility of bypassing
the system and defending
yourself against the system.
This is possible, particularly
in the larger Antilles
or in Suriname or
in the Guyanas, no?
And this gives what I call the
"counter-plantation system,"
which is the basis
for the nation.
Not yet, the nation
is being born,
but I mean the Haitians
or the Jamaicans,
et cetera, et cetera.
This is one line
of the development.
In the case for instance of
the smaller island like Saint
Vincent, Barbados,
Martinique, they
have to negotiate
within the system.
Take Barbados as
the best example,
because they were the
seat of the Royal Navy.
So you better behave yourself
or they kill you, that's all.
I mean, so you have to learn to
negotiate within their system.
But this is the
same basic position.
They are different, because
the condition in which they
are negotiating are
not the condition
in which, for instance,
Surinamese is negotiating.
And the Surinamese
have the Amerindians
who will show them how the
Amazonian et cetera, et cetera.
In any event, this
is what we are doing.
We prepare ourselves
in the negotiation
to create the group of people
who can see another reality,
create another universe, and a
universe that the "powerful,"
so-called, tend to erase, no?
And we confront
those two universes.
Now when the imperial colonial
countries enter in conflicts,
now they create a possibility
for you to break in,
you see what I mean?
So there is no difference
between the Haitian
and the Jamaican except what I
told you what happened outside.
There is no difference
between the Haitian
or Jamaican and the
Barbadian, except that one is
in the small island, which is--
Barbados is something
like 300 times
smaller than the whole
island there in Haiti,
because we have an island in
front of Port-au-Prince, La
Gonave, which is twice bigger
than Barbados, an island only.
The country is something 70
times, if you put the D.R.--
So you can imagine the
possibility of negotiation
in this island and
of the Barbadians
are quite different, no?
Not to speak of the
condition in which
Barbados was settled, no--
Barbados was settled
by couples, by British
who came with their
wives, so that one thing,
they do not have a lot
of people of color.
They use-- no, no.
They have, but they
do not have a lot.
That's one condition
that we are all,
in fact, the basic set of
position of self-respect,
sovereignty, group autonomy--
this is what is our base.
So beauty-- the beauty is
that in the worse condition
of living, thing we could
not possibly imagine that is
happening--
I do not want to
enter in the relation
between the white males
and their enslaved
and their kids and
their daughters,
what they have-- no, we
can just imagine that they
think they are all-powerful.
They do whatever they want.
They destroy themselves,
but that's another problem.
But forget about that.
We simply create our
world out of nothing.
And it's the
Caribbean world, no?
When I say out of nothing,
we do have resources
we remember from Africa.
But they are individuals
who remember that.
We have an advantage though over
the First Nations in America.
The First Nations--
all the Jews, also--
they are people
that were exploited.
But they were a nation
They have been forced to
witness the destruction
of their nation.
You see the Mayas, the
Aztec, or the Incas--
they could see the
Spaniards coming.
And they have lived that.
In our case, no, for
instance, assuming
that they get into Yoruba
country or Igbo country,
they beat them, and they take
you, and they bring you here.
You would say, oh OK, I lost.
I had just bad luck.
They got me.
But the country, nobody
can beat the Igbos.
Even if it is not true, but you
will imagine that you have not
witnessed your society
being humiliated,
your kings being a--
yes, humiliated, et
cetera, et cetera.
So we have at least that.
We start with local
experience from the day
we came here in America.
And from that local
events, we move forward
so we can create a new
society, a new world
with our experience, not with--
we do not carry all the
tradition of our society.
And we do not carry the
"deuil," the sorrow.
Or for instance, there
are some wonderful scene
in the-- among
the first nations.
[INAUDIBLE] going
all over Bolivia,
where they are
playing the conquest.
I mean, the Amerindians
are playing the conquest.
You see what I mean?
You can see all the sadness
in the winning of the alien
over-- we don't have
that possibility.
And in general, our
musical production
is quite different from theirs.
So this is what
I call the beauty
of our nation, what
we have witnessed,
what we have created.
The problem is that we have to
make our people aware of that.
And this is what
the system and what
Professor DeGraff was showing,
wants you not to see, you see?
For instance, the
beauty of Kreyòl--
Kreyòl is switching the
meaning of key function.
One of my great friends and
Professor Guillermo Bonfil
from Mexico, he said, "Indian,"
"Negroes" are colonial concept.
There were no Indians in America
before Christopher Columbus
made his mistakes.
Negroes, that you call Negroes--
I mean, I don't
know if I'm a Negro.
I mean, that's meaningless
that I am a Negro,
et cetera, et cetera.
Those are key concepts
of colonialism.
They create race.
A set of languages in
Africa has no word for race.
And in Haiti, "race"
means "family"
according to Old French, as
in "the race of DeGraff,"
"the race of Casimir."
They say, "Watch out with
the race of Rodriguez.
They are really bad
people, all of them.
They are witches."
But they mean the family, not
the race what the West covers.
So we came.
And we create another concept.
And I don't know if you know,
but as everybody knows and I
give the example so
many times, "whites"
do not mean what it means
in French or in English.
Whites-- for instance, I have
a very good friend of mine from
Jamaica I say--
when I do something
in my company,
I say I trick the white man.
But I don't mean white
men, the man who is white.
I mean, I trick the
technology, the dominant one,
the one who want the
algorithm to work that way.
I make it work another way.
I mean, this is why I
call it "the white man."
And in fact, in my proposition,
"white" means in Haiti
the responsible of the primitive
accumulation of capital.
We need to be the dominant
capitalist fellow, who
comes in, takes whatever he
sees, that he is and he take it
if he wants it, period.
No, he has been-- that's why.
So for instance, if he
comes home they will say,
"there is a Negro
asking for you."
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
JEAN CASIMIR: Period.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So if Tom goes
to Haiti, Tom becomes a Negro.
JEAN CASIMIR: A Negro.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Because "Negro"
means human being in Haiti.
JEAN CASIMIR: Period, and
the reverse is true, too.
My daughter is like
you all, my son, also.
And they are all "white"
because they are strangers.
They can't speak Kreyòl.
They don't know the habits.
They are too--
I mean, it's not discriminatory.
It's just simply they do
not know what's going on.
They do not know the
rules of the game.
That's it.
So you have changed the key
concept of the dominant system.
And you have create your world
where "tout moun se moun,"
everybody is a person.
You have create the word "moun."
I mean, the word
"moun" has nothing
to do with white,
black, male, female.
It just mean person.
Every person is a person, and
should be respected as such.
This is something you have
done when you are in the "très
fond," in the depth of misery.
To get out and to
create that group that
can survive oppression,
you had to erase that.
This is why the
Igbo disappeared,
the Congo disappeared,
the Hausa disappeared.
You become a moun.
And you have to be-- and
as far as I know in Haiti,
the worst of all sin
is to destroy life.
You have to respect
life, period.
You're not cut tree for nothing.
You don't kill an
insect for nothing.
No, no, no, no, that is a sin.
This is what is a sin.
So the beauty of
the sovereign people
is that it has been able
to invent its sovereignty
and invent itself
as distinct from.
And this is where
also it has been
able to show you, make you
see what power means in fact.
Power doesn't mean
that you're stronger,
you have more strength.
No, no, that is
not really power.
This is appearance of power
because your strengths,
you have it because
I'm powerful.
You see, I like to
tell my friend--
well, in fact, that's
an idea that is in--
Eric Williams developed, no?
Let's see, the Haitians--
to beat the Haitians,
Napoleon sent 40,000 persons.
And they lost.
So we are stronger
40,000 plus 1,
at least [LAUGHS]
because they lost.
So if you want to
know what power is,
ask us, because we beat him.
[LAUGHS]
You must understand
what power is.
Obviously, in Haiti, they are
destroying the use of Kreyòl.
They do not want Kreyòl,
as you have seen,
because Kreyòl is powerful.
You must be aware of this power
that you control, you manage.
And you are the
one who invented.
When I say something in French,
the French Academy will decide
or in Spanish,
the Royal Academy,
the Académie Royale will
decide if it is correct,
if you can say it or
if you cannot say it.
If I'm talking Jamaican,
that the shanty town
that will decide if
this can be said or not.
It's not the government,
not even the government.
It is us, us in our most inner
existence without authority.
It is the agreement between us
that we decide that what is,
for instance, shack up, shacking
up, if this is acceptable
or not.
It is not an authority.
It is the consensus
between the few people.
This is what sovereignty is.
So I will stop there.
[CLAPPING]
Oh boy, merci.
[LAUGHS]
MICHEL DEGRAFF: What you
said about white reminds
me of James Baldwin.
He has a statement--
JEAN CASIMIR: Oh yeah, exactly.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: --that "white"
is a metaphor for power.
There's no such
thing as whiteness.
"White" is Chase Manhattan Bank.
JEAN CASIMIR: Yeah, exactly.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yeah,
yeah, so thank you
for this amazing summary
of your entire approach
really to Haitian history.
So all right, so--
AUDIENCE: It's a lot
like the white thing--
for me, I hear it as--
it's a political position
sort of of your relationality
to the world, to things, to
land, to food, to people,
rather than the
color of your skin--
JEAN CASIMIR: Yes, indeed.
AUDIENCE: --your mental state
of how you see the world.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK, so
you can go around the room
and ask questions.
[INAUDIBLE],, actually Gaby
had her hand up very quickly.
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE] I think I can--
Merelin, you-- OK, all right.
STUDENT: What was
interesting that
stood out to me in the reading
was cultural homogenization
and how--
JEAN CASIMIR: Come again.
STUDENT: Cultural
homogenization--
JEAN CASIMIR:
Cultural imagination?
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
Homogenization, homogenization,
cultural homogenization.
STUDENT: --of how customs,
habits, and aspirations were
not pursued by the racist and
Eurocentric public authorities
but rather productions
carried out by the sufferers,
by the sufferers.
And I thought that it was
super interesting to think
of it that way, because I'd
personally always thought
of like, oh, they classify us--
like, we're classified
as Black, because there's
a racist system that sees us
all as like just one person
and not like
different ambitions.
But I never thought of it
as like a positive light
like how you spun it.
How it wasn't-- it was an
aspect of our survival.
We had to unify under
this one form of culture.
And I actually thought
that was interesting.
And I was wondering,
how did you get
to that point of realizing
that we formed this one
homogenized culture not out of--
just simply out of
spite, in some cases,
out of survival
and out of spite.
How did you get to this point?
That's what I--
JEAN CASIMIR: I see your point.
To be-- I think
now you make me see
that, I think I should go back
to my friend I just mentioned,
Guillermo Bonfil.
Guillermo is an anthropologist.
He said, "Indian is an
invention of the Spaniards."
When you take an Inuit--
you know Inuit,
no, from Eskimo--
and you take a Tupi, or
Mapuche, or Maya, or an Inca,
and you call all
of them "Indian."
"Indian"?
What do you mean?
Why do you want
them to be Indians?
I mean, what does somebody
who live his life in snow
has to do with Tupi or
Seminole or whatever it is?
Because you want them to work.
And you homogenize them
in your imagination
to make to work and to
exploit them the way you
want to invent that lie, OK?
So this is one thing he put.
And I start saying
that therefore
is a colonial concept.
"White" is a colonial concept.
How does the Haitian
call himself?
And I found in that book of
de Vastey, our first Haitian
historian, he called the book
The Colonial System Unveiled.
It is in English.
It's 90 pages the book has.
And I realize in these
90 pages, de Vastey
used 100 times the word
"malere yo" so "malere."
And we call ourselves "malere."
And "malere" can be a
rich man or poor man.
It means you're fragile.
You are alone.
You are vulnerable.
So even if you reach
that way, "malere" now,
because you can come, fell
down, and break your leg.
Not only that, the
importance of the "malere"
is that I was in Africa going
to a picnic with my girlfriend.
And all of a sudden came
from bandits for no reason
to pick me up.
And here I am, my girlfriend
in Saint Vincent as a slave,
me in Cuba as another slave.
We have done nothing to deserve
that "sort", that destiny, no?
We are the "malere" no?
And up to now today, the Haitian
defined himself as "malere."
And this is why my great friend
and translator, Laurent DuBois,
takes from Bob Marley
the word "sufferer."
We are sufferers.
It is not that we are a
proletarian who came from
and we could move
through social mobility
outside of the proletariat.
We do not have a common
history with the bourgeoisie.
The bourgeois and the
proletariat in Europe
come from the "bourg,"
from the city.
And they fought
together, for instance,
against the nobility
and the clergy.
And after the French
Revolution, they
split when capitalism
started moving.
But they have the same history.
They have the same language.
They have the same religion.
They have a whole hundreds
of-- no, that's not my case.
I just-- Boop!
They put me together in
front of that "planteur"
[plantation owner].
And I'm a "malere"
because I've done nothing
to deserve that suffering
thing that happened.
So when I find the
word "sufferer,"
I say, oh boy, that's it.
And this is the Kreyòl who
gave it to me, "malere."
A Haitian do not say I'm poor
or I'm-- no, I'm "malere."
And you can call
anybody "malere."
"Gade figi malereèz sa a, non"--
look at that poor lady.
You know what I mean?
Full stop.
But that has nothing to do.
OK, that means also that if
I get out of the "malheur"--
of that misery, which is
not something that came from
my will or from my
effort, it's an accident--
an accident put me in it.
An accident will
take me out of it.
My mother and my father
could work their life.
They will not make
of me a professor.
Is one day an accident, a
friend of mine was minister--
[INAUDIBLE] minister of what?
They found a scholarship.
And I get out of it.
Obviously I'm not
going to lose--
But the fact of the matter
is, you don't get out of it.
You don't get into it
because you're poor.
You don't get out of
it because you work.
Therefore, you should
respect all other "malere."
So the respect is
basic all over.
In Jamaica when I was there,
they greet you, "respect."
That's the greeting, "respect."
That's the greeting,
because I may be very rich,
I may be very poor, but I
earned the same respect.
So this is how I
would say, I think--
I get to the word "malere,"
"sufferer," because it's just
in our language.
So to my mind for
social scientists,
you should be aware and know
and study your language.
If you have a hypothesis, you
cannot put it in your own local
language, those of us
who have two languages,
you see what I mean?
[LAUGHS] He's not working.
It has to be translatable
to our language,
because we're working in--
if we work directly
in our language,
obviously that come out like--
I don't know if I
answered your question.
STUDENT: No, you're
good, thank you.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So are you
going to speak to-- piggyback
on the [INAUDIBLE]?
Yeah.
STUDENT: Well, I would just--
yeah, something if it's not--
JEAN CASIMIR: Continue...
STUDENT: Yeah.
No, just the concept of
being a "malla-gree."
JEAN CASIMIR: "Malere."
STUDENT: "Malla--
malere"-- it was--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: "Malere."
STUDENT: "Malere," yeah.
It brings me to think about
the wider idea of even
like the rational movement of
thinking that we are powerful,
which is the concept
of capitalism,
that we are so powerful.
You work hard.
You get somewhere.
JEAN CASIMIR: Yes.
STUDENT: But most people
who work really, really hard
are still--
JEAN CASIMIR: "Malere"?
[LAUGHS]
STUDENT: Yeah, so
but it kind of for me
brings a question that I like
to maybe hear your thoughts on
is the idea of poverty.
What is poverty?
If poverty is still a definition
based on acquiring property,
it's even like the
relationship to--
also relation to land.
If-- You're rich
if you own land,
rather than if you
have relationship
to land, and also
the idea that we come
in and out of circumstances
often by influences
that are outside
of our own doing.
Like, I was going on a
picnic with my girlfriend.
And suddenly I am an
enslaved person in Cuba.
This was not my own doing,
which is specifically
antithesis of the whole
capitalist approach of--
JEAN CASIMIR: Exactly.
STUDENT: --everything
is your own doing,
which doesn't humble
itself to other--
I'm just bringing it
up to say, how do we
provide a different
paradigm or perspective
to look at what is
poverty and what
is the human condition,
really, in terms
of the arrogance of
capitalism, which continues
to destroy our countries today.
Like it is-- like Haiti today
is destroyed by neoliberal--
JEAN CASIMIR: Being the
poorest country in the world,
I think this is where
I find the importance
of the decolonial studies,
because you should
see capitalism from your angle.
With all due respect
for the capitalists,
they are a set of liars.
STUDENT: Why'd you say that?
JEAN CASIMIR: I'm
going to tell you why.
They declared private
property is sacred.
They came here in America.
They took everything
that they can see.
They took it, literally.
Now in Haiti, they
took Saint-Domingue.
And the King of
Saint-Domingue, of Spain,
will give a third of
Saint-Domingue to the French.
And they declare to me
private property is sacred.
Why is it-- who gave
them Saint-Domingue?
How could they take
it for themselves,
you see what I mean?
Use the Seminole and this
thing presented by Peck, no?
You come there, you take my
land, and you take that man
and you tell him he's yours?
How do you manage?
I don't know if you see
that the documentary
of Raoul Peck on the--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: It's called
Exterminate all the Brutes.
JEAN CASIMIR: Exterminate
all the Brutes.
The brutes come.
They take the country.
They take over the country.
They take all the wealth.
When they finish with the
wealth in the Caribbean,
they go in Mexico,
they go in Peru.
They take everything
they had, no?
And they start their capitalism,
I mean, they start developing.
And they're telling me
private property is sacred,
that we have to respect that.
How come?
If you start lying, you
seize what is not yours.
No, but you declare that
God gave me half of--
whose God, yours or mine?
What do we have
to see with that?
So the question of
poverty, you impoverish me,
because you define
wealth the way you want.
You take it.
And you say I have
to respect it.
And you have a set of
institutions-- school,
et cetera, et cetera--
to prove to me
that I deserve to be poor,
for instance, I am Black,
I'm the son of Ham, and
all sort of really, lies.
Not only that, this question
of Ham-- there is a verse.
I don't have it in
mind, but that is good.
Well, in the Exodus, it's
said if you take a person,
you sell the person,
you deserve a death.
But on the other
hand, they're going
to say the son of Ham's will--
So they are a set of liars.
And I do not have
to believe that.
to respect that.
And studies made
will show that--
I mean, I'm talking about
Madiou, another historian who
was a member of the oligarchy
for the whole 19th century.
He said the system is
corrupt, because corruption
made the colonial system.
So you cannot expect today the
authorities of Haiti not to be
corrupt.
Same thing in the US, the
system is based on corruption.
How could you take the
land of the Indians?
You go and kill Indians,
and now you make them poor.
You create them.
You create their poverty.
Not only you create
the poverty, you
start ruling them with English
when they were being ruled.
They are-- et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera.
So I think poverty and wealth--
and this is why also we must be
aware of what we call wealth.
Wealth is what allows us to
survive, to be, to exist.
This is where imagination
comes, invention comes,
all non-material
knowledge will come.
I'm not belittling technology,
because you have done something
with the ways you have taken.
And I want to--
I respect that, no?
But this is your interest.
Now my job is with
my imagination
to try to use your technology
to foster, to empower my people.
You see what I mean?
I mean, this is how
more or less I see.
Haiti is the poorest
country in the world,
according to the
establishment's views.
But as I told you, Lloyd
Best, this famous economist
from Trinidad, said Haiti is
the richest country in America
according to Lloyd Best.
[LAUGHS] And he wrote a
long article on that--
I could look for it--
but to show you that
you have a voice
It's not that we like
poverty, we like--
no, no, that's not the point.
The point is that
you respect yourself.
You like yourself.
You protect yourself.
And these things are
quite clear also on that.
You know what I mean?
This is the-- and you
must be aware of that.
This is a problem.
Don't let people
divert your attention
towards those material things.
It is important.
I have to drink water
and clean water.
I cannot do without it, no?
But it is not that that made me.
As we say in Haiti,
you are not going
to have that to the
graveyard with you.
You're going to go to
the graveyard naked.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Let's go
around to it with [INAUDIBLE]..
Write down your
question and then--
STUDENT: And it's not-- it was
just going a [? long way. ?]
STUDENT: I have four
questions into one.
JEAN CASIMIR: Lift your mask.
STUDENT: Oh, I have like
four questions into one.
But they all center around
the counter-plantation system.
JEAN CASIMIR: Around the
counter-plantation system?
STUDENT: Yeah, so do you think
that the fact that France
was "a master away from
home" helped cultivate
the counter-plantation system?
And coming from a
Dominican person,
like someone who was
governed by Spain,
do you think that is also
why Haiti was able to be
successful in this system?
Meanwhile, the DR, we
still have haciendas
and "modern plantations."
And thinking about
success, how successful
was the
counter-plantation system?
And are we measuring
success on the basis
of do our people remember or
are our people knowledgeable,
or we're measuring on a--
have we managed to dismantle
the capitalist society that
the Pearl of the Antilles
was built upon?
JEAN CASIMIR: I'm going
to answer the first half
and then you reformulate
the second half.
The hacienda could be
the proper translation
for the word plantation.
So the French never had the
counter-plantation system.
The French has an "hacienda."
It organized the
hacienda properly
as a capitalist system,
a rational system where
every single input
oriented toward an output
called a merchandise
or commodity
to produce more commodities.
That is the plantation,
the hacienda.
Now to save some
money, the owner
of the hacienda
or the plantation
have some what we call provision
grounds, some "konoko."
Where they won't pay you, they
have you working on the konoko.
OK, now you're on the konoko,
on the provision grounds.
You're going to organize
the lakou, the yard.
a system of solidarity
and reciprocity where
you protect your people.
So you're making use of one
move of the dominant system
for your own ends.
We call that you serve, you
utilize the dominant system
to serve your own ends.
So therefore, the
counter-plantation system
is born within the plantation
system, within the hacienda.
And when 1791-- let's
say, 117, [INAUDIBLE]----
17-- [INAUDIBLE] '89.
When the French
Revolution started
and the planters,
the "hacenderos,"
start fighting each other, you
start developing your konokos.
And this is when the
nation is going, really,
to take a structure but
on a national level.
And since I'm there,
what is important is that
the counter-plantation
system, the villages--
it's a village system.
The villages are isolated.
They are microclimates.
They produce certain goods.
If you are in the mountain,
you can have spices,
you can have fruits, et cetera.
If you're in the
flatland, you have mango,
you have banana, et cetera.
In the mountain,
you have coffee.
So you have to exchange, no?
And you are going
to create, this
is our case, the
internal market,
because there was no
internal market in term
of colonial time.
What was important was only
the export of the commodity.
So you create the
counter-plantation
you create the internal market.
And who manage internal market?
The female higglers.
The woman was going to tide
of the nation, the women
the tide of the
nation, not the men.
The men can work,
whatever it is.
But those who are responsible
to moving goods and moving money
are female up to now.
Your parents when
they send money home,
they didn't send it to any man.
They send it to a woman,
because she manage money.
She manage resources.
So she will be
the one who will--
tied up-- what I call
the "twa wòch dife"--
the three pillars of
the nation-- community,
internal market, and women.
But what tied them up?
Creole language.
You see what I mean?
You don't see a higgler
speaking standard English.
[LAUGHS] No.
No.
Higglers speak rough
Jamaican English.
And this is what is
sustaining the nation.
On top of that, an
oligarchy is going to--
OK, now give me the second
part of your question.
[LAUGHS]
STUDENT: So my second
question is just like--
I mean, you kind of
answered it already.
But how successful is the
counter-plantation system?
And are we measuring
success on the basis
of do our people
remember our history,
are they knowledgeable?
Or are we measuring
on how we manage
to dismantle the
capitalistic society that
was established in the Pearl
of the Antilles or Haiti?
JEAN CASIMIR: Wonderful.
The counter-plantation system
explains the whole 19th century
Haiti, no?
How we can measure his success?
We started independence
with maximum 350,000 people.
We ended up the 19th century
with 2 million people.
We multiplied.
But this is not codified
by the government.
Government want to
recreate the plantation,
want to recreate haciendas.
They will not talk about that.
But the fact of the
matter is we did that.
Not only did we--
did we do that, we--
I mean, the Haitians, real--
I call them Guinean
Haitians, no.
The Haitian, real Haitians
start absorbing the oligarchy,
because the oligarchy
has no use for French,
because they had no
relation, nor religion.
So they started speaking Kreyòl.
And they had no--
it isn't until 1860
that the Catholic Church
acknowledged the
existence of Haiti
and started sending priests
and 12 or 15, whatever it is.
So the people have to use in the
spirituality of Obeah or Vodou.
So they start being absorbed by.
Now what makes that possible?
It's not that we
are so special, no.
At that time, the big
empires of the West
were entering in the
imperial colonial time.
They are conquering
Africa, conquering
the [INAUDIBLE], et cetera.
So they could do--
the Caribbean economy
becomes totally secondary.
And you had beet sugar,
et cetera, et cetera,
so they forget about
us, thanks God!
So we could develop.
So for instance, if you
take the case of, let's say,
to come back to Barbados--
boy, a good thing there is no
[Bajan?] here.
You will challenge me, stop
thinking about Barbados.
But in Barbados for
instance, the planters
had a hold on the land.
And the production of
sugarcane after emancipation
was higher than before.
To tell you the level of
exploitation of the Bajans,
to such an extent they were so
attacked by hunger that they
start migrate to Guyana and
then to build the Panama Canal,
same thing with Martinique
where the planters could
have a hold on the land.
So they had to
migrate outside, no?
Not only that, the migration
to the Panama Canal,
to the oil field of
Venezuela, et cetera,
was such that some countries in
the Caribbean had no more men.
You have only male,
old male, kids.
And a set of--
Eric WIlliams even points that
out, homosexuality started
developing to such an
extent for instance,
in the St Lucia,
the word "zanmi,"
"friend," means "lesbian."
I was making studies in Creole,
no, in Creole Trinidadian.
And I said, oh, and so and
so is my zanmi, my friend.
And the St. Lucian said,
you can't say that.
You can't say-- he
can't be your friend.
And I say, why?
Friend means lesbian, because
the word become normal.
And it's not that
lesbian [INAUDIBLE]
you to deface or to diminish.
No, no, no, no, that's normal.
The two ladies live together.
They are zanmi.
That was normal, because there
was no male figure, adult male.
In several islands-- Eric
Williams even mentioned that
in some Caribbean
islands that regret--
I mean, their populations
started diminishing.
I mean, in the case
of Jamaica, this
is the moment of the
migration toward Costa Rica,
toward the movement
of Marcus Garvey,
because there is no
way you can attack
the land of the British owners.
In the case, of Haiti
we didn't go frontally
toward the land property.
We start occupying it.
And the state didn't
have strength enough
to kick us out of the land.
There are several elements
there I could-- well, in the DR,
I think something
like that happened,
because plantation really
started with Trujillo.
The Americans came.
And they needed to
heal-- to help them.
And you had land.
Not only that, the
Dominican Republic I think
developed a set of cattle
raising to complete,
to serve the part of colonial
French plantation system.
They will sell cattle, no?
So there is a whole
tradition of cattle raising.
And when Haitians
start their migration,
they start since they were
basically agriculturalists,
you see, peasants,
they start planting.
And this annoyed Trujillo,
because anything he
made to occupy this land--
if he gave land, the Dominicans
go toward cattle raising.
And the one who was taking
profit of the land given
was Haitian origin people.
That was their
tradition, et cetera,
that created certain
conflicts with the state,
because the capital of
the [INAUDIBLE] Eastern
part of the country, not the
central part of the country.
And incidentally,
I don't know if you
know that most of our heroes
of this period were from--
if not from the Dominican,
from the border--
Hinche, these-- Lascahobas--
This part in-between the
two countries, and this
is where we had most strongest
opponent to US occupation.
Yes, indeed, Charlemagne
Péralte, the name is "Peralta,"
in fact, not "Péralte."
[LAUGHS] You know what I mean?
We say "Péralte."
But he's "Peralta,"
et cetera, et cetera.
Did I answer your
second question?
STUDENT: Yeah, thank you.
STUDENT: I had two questions.
One of them is based on the
counter-plantation system.
JEAN CASIMIR: No,
no, remove your mask.
STUDENT: I had two questions.
One of them is based on the
counter-plantation system.
But my question was, would you
say that the counter-plantation
system was an idea given to
the enslaved by the colonizers
given that--
because I know in
history books, they
tell you that the
colonizers made
the enslaved find their own
food to sustain themselves.
So I was wondering
is that, do you
think that's an idea that
they were given in a sense?
Or was that just a byproduct?
JEAN CASIMIR: That's one?
STUDENT: That's one question.
And the second
question is, while I
was reading the
chapter I remember
the podcast I was listening to.
And one of the guests was
saying that they believe
that Haiti should
have waited before,
that Haiti should not have
done the revolution when
they did it.
JEAN CASIMIR: They
were too early.
[LAUGHTER]
STUDENT: Right,
so my question is,
what do you think about that?
Because in my opinion, I
could see if they had waited,
it would change the trajectory
of the slave revolutions
that came after.
But I just wanted to know
what you thought about that.
JEAN CASIMIR: OK, too early.
[LAUGHTER]
Listen, first of all, the
counter-plantation system,
I call it
counter-plantation system
because it's not the classical
peasantry, simply for that,
because the classical
peasantry is self-sufficient.
If you take, for instance,
Mesoamerica or even
Central Europe, the peasants
produce even their instrument
of production, of the-- yes,
instrument of production,
like Cuba, no?
Not only that, they
have even the textile.
There is no more
sophisticated textile
than the Guatemalan textile.
They weave their thing
into something great.
But if you are an enslaved,
there is a certain number
of things you cannot produce
yourself, like button,
an instrument, machete,
because you don't have any--
while the Africans were
very skillful in dealing
with iron, but in
the Caribbean, where
are you going to find iron?
So you have a
"peasantry," in quote,
that must produce an excess to
exchange for the other good.
So it's not exactly a peasant.
It's why I call it the
counter-plantation system.
Now, I don't think the system
comes from the-- that has
nothing to do with the planters,
because the planter cannot
imagine a type of relation,
family relation like we have.
First of all, to understand
really our family,
we must take into
account the fact
that the slave has no gender.
They have sex but no gender,
like cattle have no gender.
So the first creation of the
counter-plantation system
will be the invention of women.
We create our women.
We create our agenda.
We create our men.
We have to imagine
a form of structure
where that female and
that male can function.
It did not function
under slavery.
It function in the
counter-plantation system.
Now, we create also the form
of a pairing--"mariage," no?--
the formal-- because
do we have the mono--
bi-- I don't know.
Mono parent--
STUDENT: Monogamous?
JEAN CASIMIR: Monogamy?
Do we have polygamy?
Do we have--
I mean, that's-- up to now,
we cannot solve that question.
Let me tell you an anecdote.
STUDENT: Nobody can.
JEAN CASIMIR: Particularly
in our countries.
For instance, I was telling
my wife, my companion
that the young
lady walking by me
is telling that
so-and-so of his friend
is not there, because
the husband went
to visit his married woman.
And also, her
friend is available.
She can visit her friend,
because the husband
of her friend go to
see her married woman.
So I tell my wife, "If I
say you my married woman,
what would you say?"
She say, [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHS] because
the fact of assuming
that the companion
has a married woman
means that they are polygamous.
And she is not-- she doesn't
feel any bad about that.
She's living in polygamy.
And the first lady who married
the man is a married woman.
And she is also the woman.
And for the married woman, don't
you believe that this means--
for the ladies, that
means-- no, no, that
means the fellow is
not there all the time
to bother them, period.
They can do their thing.
They organize their life.
Simply in the house, some
sexual partner when they need
or where they
arrange themselves.
It's a different set,
conception of family.
Not only that, when
you have a quarrel,
you have conflicts,
the lady, who
is the weakest
person in the couple,
she is not going toward
the husband to help her.
She going to the
eldest brother, she
look in her family who
will protect her, not
in the family of the husband.
She may, but that's
not necessary.
What is it say is
that the husband--
I mean, sorry, the
husband-- the head
of the fam-- of her family.
The eldest brother or whoever
is the head must come out.
If the husband come,
that will help.
But that's not the point.
She goes to--
So we have another
concept, organization,
which is not
codified, because we
are so brainwashed by
the Catholic Church.
We're looking for a--
couples all over.
And we're saying, the
men are so promiscuous.
They don't take
care of their kids.
It's not the father.
Well, I won't give
more anecdote.
I was going to give
you another one, but--
[LAUGHS]
The other one is the following.
I was teaching in
Congo with my wife.
We were both teachers.
And one of the essays
that my wife received
said, my eldest father was
sleeping under the tree.
My wife say, what's that?
So we had the Congolese
living with us.
He said, listen, what
is an eldest father?
He has a younger one?
And the Congolese start
laughing, like hell,
he takes five minutes
before he answered.
He says, yes, because
the word for "father"
is the same for "uncle."
[LAUGHS] That means the
eldest brother of his mother
as a "father."
And in Haiti, everybody
calls me "father."
When I go Southern Mexico, they
call me "abuelo," grandfather.
Everybody calls me "abuelo"--
and "mi abuelo" let me do
that, in Haiti, father--
to such an extent
the police stop me
and say, "Father,
give me your license."
I say, "Just a minute, my son."
"How come you call me son?"
I say, "But you just
called me father."
[LAUGHTER]
You see, I mean,
these are definitions
that are contextual.
And we use it.
But this is not codified.
And the state do
not want to hear
from that, because
the state have
to be at par with the
international community.
And there is no way you
make them respect that.
And I give this story
to Professor DeGraff
of that friend of mine who is a
member of the great commission
of human rights.
Now, when we say they should
make laws for the people who
shack up, he told me shacking
up cannot be object of law
because it is a crime.
[LAUGHS]
I mean, you can imagine
a lawyer saying that.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: A
human-rights lawyer?
JEAN CASIMIR: Human rights.
Somebody of my age, a
little bit younger than me--
I mean, but this is what
he received at school.
STUDENT: But are we also
talking about the difference
between citizenship,
being a citizen, which
is what the state
wants us to be,
"citizens," and then being
a people of the lakou
or community--
JEAN CASIMIR: Yes, exactly.
STUDENT: Of like calling you
"father," not calling you
"citizen."
JEAN CASIMIR: "Citizen," in
our case, in our tradition,
is the land owner who has a
certain number of enslaved.
Those are "active citizens."
And the others are
"passive citizens."
[LAUGHTER]
STUDENT: That's
what we're all being
pushed to become, less
of community people
and more of citizens than--
JEAN CASIMIR: No,
but the people do not
want to be "citizens" either.
They do not want the state.
The state never did
anything for them
since they exist,
they start existing.
I mean, they don't
want to participate.
STUDENT: I hope so,
but I mean, more people
want to be citizens is
a problem in the world.
I think the concept--
JEAN CASIMIR: No, I'm
talking about local history.
For in the world, I don't know.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: It is a
question that Iana asked about.
Was it too early?
JEAN CASIMIR: Oh yeah, that's
a really important question.
OK, first of all, at
least in sociology,
you don't decide
what's going to happen.
Society moves.
And we had an opportunity
we went through.
We were not asked to do.
For instance, De Vastey speak
of the "Haitians in spite of"--
the "forced Haitian."
Not talking about the
set of the freed men,
emancipated persons who wanted
to move and to be French
and who actually maintained
France or French up to now
as the key of Haiti.
But Napoleon had decided to
kill them and to deport them.
So they had to fight with
the Maroons for independence.
So he called them
"Les Haïtiens"--
Haitians in spite of
themselves, forced Haitians.
And those Haitians were
very important in the fight
for independence together
with the Maroons.
If not, we will have a modern
society and Bush Negroes
like in Suriname.
And then they would
conquer us again.
So they were important.
Nonetheless, they didn't
choose to fight France.
France forced them
to fight them.
That's one aspect.
Second aspect, which is very,
very, very important, when
most people are saying
Haiti is independent,
was independent too soon--
and not anybody said that.
I'm talking about Aimé Césaire
I'm talking about Derek
Walcott.
I mean, people who say, how
could Haiti so rich is so poor
now?
That's not possible.
They have been
independent too much.
No, well, OK, I'm
not saying what
is the level of living
in the other countries
of the Caribbean, because I can
say the same thing for the US.
I don't think the US
is that good either.
But OK, I grant--
whatever they want,
I grant them that.
But what they do not
take into account
is the fact that the Haitians,
by being independent in 1804,
protected the
Haitian from death.
Let me tell you
the circumstances.
By 1803 or 1802 or
1801-- but anyway,
before Haiti become
independent, Napoleon
gave the order to kill all
the Blacks who were rebel
and to re-people the islands.
But he didn't give the order.
He started implementing
this order in Guadeloupe
by General Richepanse.
He started killing
Blacks, killing them.
And the Guadeloupeans who had
started the revolution, when
they realized they are
dying, they decided,
OK, let's try to live another
day, so we will fight tomorrow.
And they stop fighting.
And they surrender.
And they were re-enslaved
because they were fighting
against re-enslavement.
When they stopped fighting,
they found that 10% of them
were already killed.
So they were about to kill them.
In the case of Haiti,
they start the same thing
at such a point that the Poles
who he had sent to fight us--
they were Pol--
they were peasants--
realizing that they say,
no, we are not participating
in killing civilians and kids.
We didn't come here for that.
And they move and fight
with the Haitians.
And this is also another
reason why Dessalines declared
that the Poles were
Black, because this
is what we call Black.
It's not being Black tinted.
OK, so Haiti became independent.
And Napoleon could not kill
those Haitians to have--
too many people, they say.
In the countries that remain
colonies that were not
independent so soon,
as I just told you,
you had to let a set
of out migration,
because you had
hungers in Martinique,
hungers in Barbados,
hungers in-- great hungers,
because the white people--
Barbados is a typical case--
intensified the exploitation
of their former
enslaved and produce
much more without
introducing new technology.
You see, Barbados was
producing more than Cuba
when Cuba had production
with new technology.
So they increased the
exploitation of the Bajans.
And more Bajans die in Barbados.
And more Bajans had
to leave the country
in conditions that were very
similar to the slave trade.
So it is-- you didn't
choose to be independent.
The opportunity comes.
There is a crack in the system.
And you move.
And you establish yourself.
But how did you done that?
What would happen?
Because now that
gives us one way out.
Haitians become independent.
We multiply the population, et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
But our development is
based on inner management
of our inner system.
While we do not have one
thing the Bajans have
or the Jamaicans
also, they know how
to negotiate with
the other person.
We don't know that up to now.
It is now that we are learning
what happened with the West.
When the Americans
occupied Haiti,
the president of
Haiti, Dartiguenave,
had no idea of what the
Americans were up to.
He thought they came to help us.
He could not imagine
they came to exploit us.
You can imagine the fellow
president of the Republic
has no idea of the occupant.
Not only that, the other
day when the US, no,
the UN head of mission visited
the general headquarters
of the army, in the
general headquarters
of the army, all the big
chiefs of the US occupation
were there as founder
of the Haitian army.
He said, where you have found
an independent country where
the occupant is put as
the creator of the army,
of the national army?
You can imagine
Jamaica's headquarters
of the army with all the British
there who created the army.
For God's sake, at
least take them off.
But in Haiti up to now,
and they had that-- no, not
up to now, because
Aristide ended this army,
but to tell you the situation.
So is Haiti independent
too early or not?
OK, I don't know.
Ask-- as Vastey
would say, as those
who died on the boat
going-- and the life
of the Caribbean
people in Panama
during the construction
of the, like-- there's
a wonderful documentary
made here in the US
on the Caribbean people
building the Panama Canal.
Oh boy, you are to cry.
You are to cry.
And up to now they
are protesting
the way they beat them,
the way they treat them,
how they died, I mean, in
Culebra, building the Panama
Canal, because you should not
forget that the 19th century is
the time of Jim Crow laws here.
And those who are
building the canal,
they are the Jim Crow fellows.
I mean, they are--
just have when the
Black North American,
when African-Americans
start voting,
to give you an idea of what
happened 50 years earlier
in countries that were
not even America--
this is how-- you
know, you can imagine
what was going on there.
Now, so was Haiti
independent too early?
I mean, are we comparing
what is left of Barbados,
because we let a
set of Barbadian
die, because this
is what happened.
Barbados is the country,
at least compared to Haiti,
where even--
everybody has secondary school
diploma, everybody, everybody.
In Haiti, oh, I think we can
count them with your hand.
And those who have
it, we don't know
how bad is that instruction--
in education-- schooling is.
So obviously, this allows
certain regions to go forward.
But how many of them died?
How many of them are not there?
Obviously, I'm sure that
the state will not speak
too much about the suffering.
Martinique knew hunger, while
Haiti was at the time in what
Manigat called-- one of our
historians called ""le bonheur
vivrier," the village happiness.
I mean, we had full-fledged
village happiness.
And the knowledge--
we allowed the state
building one hospital.
Just the knowledge of the
people, which was not too much,
you could go--
But anyway, that was enough
to multiply the population
by five.
And not only that, there is no
country in the whole America
where you have a normal
increase of the population
naturally because
of the population.
All of them increased
the population
through migration
coming from Europe.
And at this 19th century
when they were migrating
toward the Latin
America or South Africa,
et cetera, et cetera,
I want to know
why they were leaving their
country, not because they
have too much.
Why the Italians left Italy?
Why the Spaniard left
Spain, the Vatican City?
Why the Dutch and the British
left in the 19th century
when the Industrial
Revolution is
taking place, when you have
capitalism developing itself
and conquering the whole world?
What was the level of living,
the number of Swedish people
who went from Sweden to the US?
And you can see their
photo and they're
showing they are migrants.
Killing Indians, OK, but
listen, if you are so well-fed
in Swede, you are not coming
here to kill-- in Sweden--
to kill Indians.
Stay home.
So all the things, they are
not spoken, this is not spoken.
And in that time, the
Haitian will multiply.
This is another idea
of wealth, to answer.
You see the wealth?
What is wealth?
STUDENT: My question?
So I'll say my general
question and then
give a little bit of
background for how I got there.
But it seems very general.
But my question is
like, what is your why.
And the way I got to
that was I think--
JEAN CASIMIR: Do you
say, what is your why?
STUDENT: Your why,
like why you're
doing this, why you have this
power, and things like this.
The way I got to
this question is
I think every week
we do readings.
We come, someone presents.
And while it is based
on the readings,
it's so based on
themselves as well.
And like I said,
I've learned so much
about all the people in this
class and what is their why,
and like why they're
here, what they
take from like every
reading and stuff like that.
So I wanted to know like
specifically and personally
what is your why.
JEAN CASIMIR: My why?
STUDENT: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
JEAN CASIMIR: You mean.
STUDENT: I love your question.
JEAN CASIMIR: You
mean, you are mean.
Let me tell you.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: That's
a good question.
I love it.
JEAN CASIMIR: Yeah, because
the colonial study implies
that you position yourself.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: That's right,
absolutely, absolutely.
JEAN CASIMIR: It's a long story.
You know, I'm very old.
[LAUGHTER]
My why is long.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: How old are you?
JEAN CASIMIR: 84.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: 84,
that's what I thought.
[LAUGHTER]
1938?
In one of the
interviews, you say
that it's important to look
when you were born, 1938.
JEAN CASIMIR: First, so I
belong to a generation that
come exactly after the war.
I'm born in '38.
The war, the Second
World War is starting.
And I start seeing,
discovering reality
after the war in 1946, which is
the time exactly when we have
what we call the
1946 revolution.
This 1946 revolution
is the consequence
of the 1915 US occupation.
When the US occupied
Haiti, they occupied Haiti
with two things-- the
big stick in one hand,
and on the other hand,
the Jim Crow policy.
So you can imagine they
reintroduced in Haiti
the whole color problem.
This is when Price-Mars
come with the "Ainsi parla
l'oncle" on Vodou, et cetera,
and when you have the Négritude
issue being brewed in
Europe and in Haiti.
And you have Duvalier and
what we call Négrisme,
going on to answer the
opposition in the country where
the Americans were putting in
light-skinned people all over,
et cetera.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So
Jean Price-Mars,
to give some background,
was a scholar
who gave the idea that, look,
we have to go back to Africa
to understand who
we are as Haitians.
So Africa is beautiful.
Black is beautiful.
And that was in opposition
to the Americans that came in
and that were very racist.
So that's what he's
referring to as Négritude.
JEAN CASIMIR: Yeah, and
interestingly enough,
Jean Price-Mars is the
big, son of big landowners
in the countryside,
like Péralte, I mean,
because it is good not to
put everybody in one bag.
He's a "latifundista,"
a big landowner.
But he is proud of his
position, of what he is.
And he's a doctor.
He's a diplomat.
So anyway...
So in 1946, end of the
war, who was-- well,
the war ended a
little bit earlier.
Who is president is
light-skinned Élie Lescot.
And therefore, the students--
oh boy, OK.
The students made a
so-called "revolution."
And we said, Haiti
is a Black country.
The president has to be Black.
It cannot be
whatever is the idea.
But they use the term "Black,"
which is a colonial concept.
And you had as president a
Black fellow, Dumarsais Estimé,
who is a big landowner also.
You see what I mean?
So you are going to have a
possibility of development,
because that's the
epoch when the US come
with the idea of development.
Eisenhower, etc.
Truman, when
development-- so they
are going to take a whole set
of policies toward development.
We have to develop the country
to make the country capitalist,
modernize the country,
et cetera, et cetera.
So that's the period when
I am going to school.
I mean, during that period.
OK, so to-- jumping over plenty
many things, here I come.
I found a scholarship.
And I'm studying in Mexico.
So I want to know why is
it that we are so poor.
After such a wonderful economy,
a wonderful revolution,
after such a wonderful
independence, how
come we are poor?
And I start studying that.
And I wrote my license, my--
STUDENT: Thesis?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: [INAUDIBLE]?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JEAN CASIMIR: A
[INAUDIBLE] my first level,
my-- before master.
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
Bachelor's thesis.
JEAN CASIMIR: My bachelor's
thesis on the Republic
of Haiti, where I went
through the history trying
to explain why we are the way
we are, "poor," quote unquote,
because I am searching
for development.
At the same time, at the end of
this period, I entered the UN.
And I ended up also in
the Economic Commission
for Latin America, always
after prohibition is run,
after development.
Let's develop the country.
So I'm working on development to
find out that this is the law.
It's like the carrot you
put in front of the donkey.
I mean, you can run.
You can run, you
never get there.
[LAUGHS] et cetera, et cetera.
In the process, I
discover "culture."
I realized that Haitians
from the very beginning
have two cultures.
And I wrote my PhD thesis
with the title "The Oppressed
Culture."
I was studying in Mexico.
I was very much influenced
by their conception
of the "Creole."
So I call it "the
dominant culture."
Well, at that time,
Mexico was in the process
of "Castellanización," to teach
Spanish to the First Nations,
not because-- as far
as the ideology was,
that would help them to develop.
Now they will modernize,
speaking Spanish,
because their language
is not the language.
It's kind of dialogue
they are speaking,
things that are older
than French and Spanish.
But anyway, so
they want to erase
that to teach them to speak.
So the Creole Mexicans, they
were the dominant class.
So the dominant
culture in Haiti I
call it the "Creole
culture" as opposed
to an "oppressed culture," which
is the culture of the peasants.
And I entered in dichotomy
between "Creole" and "Bosal."
The Haitian creolized and the
Bosal just fresh from Africa.
And that gives a false
idea of the process.
But that's not the point.
That gives the basis for my
study on oppressed culture.
And I show how Africa was
erased from the history of Haiti
because of the dominance
of the Creoles.
OK, so--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Is it
"Creole" in the sense
of those who were
born in the Caribbean
and who basically
were assimilated?
JEAN CASIMIR: Out of mixed--
with the assimilated, too, no?
And also-- well, I
proposed acculturation.
So the Creoles were those
who were acculturated,
who had learned the
Western culture who
were ruling the country, who
were the elite, et cetera,
et cetera.
You see what I mean.
While the other one was speaking
Creole [Kreyòl] the language,
and they were the
oppressed culture,
they have all sort of
other institutions,
all sort of other systems who
were "traditional, backward."
I would probably
not use "backward,"
but they were traditional.
They are not modern.
And you had to pull them
out of their traditionalism
to modernize them, more or less.
Well, that was a,
let's see, one stage.
And at the same
time, I'm discovering
that the UN has
five or six decades
of investing in
development, always
coming back to square one.
[LAUGHS] There was
no development.
But they were investing
in decades of development.
And I was working in
that, following privilege.
At the same time, I had
used-- and since the theory
of dependency--
I mean, the problem
of development
in Latin America
and the Caribbean
is that we are dependent
of the large countries,
the rich countries.
And we should try
to have a set of--
a sector of our economy that
will pull the other sector.
And this sector will
control it through
the national bourgeoisie.
You see what I mean?
This was very common in the
'60s to explain the situation.
Then you try to have an
independent sector who
will be the locomotive to
pull the train, et cetera,
et cetera.
But obviously
nobody never had it.
Or those who had
it were co-opted.
But this is what we were using.
But I still was
quite dissatisfied,
because that will not
take Haiti out of poverty.
And not only that, that
implies Duvalier as a dictator,
the son of Duvalier, et cetera,
et cetera, an effort by the US
to industrialize the country,
et cetera, et cetera, all coming
always back to this poverty.
So this is when I start--
first of all, I
move out of the idea
of "development," realizing
that "development" is not
bringing us anywhere.
And therefore, what?
In the process of studying
the oppressed culture,
I found the
counter-plantation system.
I found the village society.
And I was, by that time,
working in Trinidad
with my Caribbean friends.
I started realizing
that plantation--
because we are
talking development--
is the locomotive, no,
the key part of the train.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: The engine?
JEAN CASIMIR: The
engine of development,
et cetera, et cetera.
And I accept with them
that the bush society is
a ...metayage... land tenure?
Not land tenure... metayage?
You say that in Saint Lucia.
Oh, boy--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: I was about
to say that, actually.
Let me look it up.
JEAN CASIMIR: When you
rent the land to somebody,
[NON-ENGLISH].
STUDENT: Oh, I have
an Arabic word for it.
[LAUGHTER]
JEAN CASIMIR: Anyway,
so I start thinking
of this form of production,
sharecropping, where
traditional, because you
should go into a plantation,
into a trade union,
et cetera, et cetera.
I must tell you also that
the same time with Cuba
is making is revolution.
Cuba is nationalizing.
Cuba is moving forward.
And we were all
obviously pro-Cuban,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
So we are seeing that.
But this is not
working in Haiti.
I mean, this is not work--
not only this is not working,
the Cubans in their
efforts are helping Angola.
They are helping Bolivia.
Haiti is just around the corner,
[LAUGHS] et cetera, et cetera.
So people start to
have doubts, no?
And I start seeing that the
economic development is not
giving us a result. And we have
to think in terms of culture.
And I start moving with the
counter-plantation system,
looking at it at its importance.
And I start discovering the
need for working with Kreyòl,
for participation of the people
in the development system.
OK, so reaching that point,
I wrote a series of article
and publish a book called
"Haiti and Its Elites..."--
no?
"...Dialogue of Death."
Of "deaf"?
People who can't hear.
STUDENT: Deaf.
JEAN CASIMIR: Deaf?
OK, no?
And this is the-- let's see,
the book announcing Haiti
and the decolonial history,
because it is at that time that
I met my friends of the colonial
thinking who thought that
my book on oppressed
culture, in fact,
announces the whole
decolonial thinking,
because I was trying to see--
and this is the question
I was asking myself,
since my book on oppressed
culture is my PhD thesis.
So my PhD thesis is saying,
is asking, what is it
that we have done for ourselves?
I mean, plantation, planting,
all sorts of things--
but we have nothing
to do in plantation.
That was imposed on us, no?
I didn't raise the
question like that.
But I could have
done it in that book,
saying that a plantation is
not a Caribbean institution.
It is the time when Caribbean
is called "plantation America."
I said, no, no, we
have something else.
Caribbean cannot be English
Caribbean, Dutch Caribbean,
French Caribbean.
Caribbean is Caribbean, period.
I mean, there is
something we have done,
which is not English,
French, British, or Dutch,
what have you, or Spanish.
So I start looking for
what we have learned.
This is what I call
"a dialogue of deaf,"
because the elite is French,
the elite speak French,
the laws are French, et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
And in one discussion in Aquin,
I was presenting the book.
And somebody said,
but what you're saying
there is not an elite.
It is an oligarchy.
I say, oh God, I should
have thought of that,
because elite is very simple.
If we are 10
shoemakers, the best
are the elite of the shoemakers.
But if the best does not
behave as giving best shoes,
they will go down
among the others.
And other people
will come as elite.
This is not the case
in our societies.
These elite of French
speaking people
never go down, because
they are an oligarchy.
So I realized that we
do not have an elite.
We have an elite, the
Vodou priests, the manbo.
And those are elites.
But those who govern the
country-- our French speakers--
are not necessarily elite.
In fact, they are not elite.
They are those who
are holding us down.
And therefore, I
start now discovering
the decolonial thought.
Let me study what we have
done, how we have done that.
How did the Haitian
came to be Haitian?
And what makes a Haitian
different from a Jamaican,
from a Vincentian, or
from a Trinidadian?
Because their local
history's different.
You see, when you
take-- for instance,
I had the good fortune through
the Economic Commission
to work 10 years in Trinidad.
And I tell the Trinidadians
that you never knew slavery.
You were a happy people.
And when you think
of it, that's true.
The Trinidadians, Trinidad was
Spaniard, Spanish, Spaniard,
no?
When Haiti started its
revolution beginning of 1790s,
Spain starts receiving
the planters running away
from Saint-Domingue
to such an extent
that Trinidadians speak the
same Creole that we speak.
And we understand each
other, because they will come
to Trinidad with their slaves.
And there are several
examples like that.
And then the Spaniards
and the French planters,
which Trinidadians called French
Creoles, the French planter
and the slave will
establish Creole
as the basic language of the
land together with Spanish,
in certain pockets speak
Spanish, French, [? but-- ?]
so the Spanish and Creole,
above all, Spanish and Creole.
So soon after, the British--
Spain cedes the
island to the British.
And in the ceded island, the
British has to recognize,
it acknowledges the
internal laws of this land.
So the British were governing.
And the Trinidadians were
speaking Creole and French.
The British was the owner.
So I realized at that
point in time, by 1817,
we are 1803, 1804
when the French start
flowing in the country.
By 10 years or 20 years
after, the British
stopped the slave trade.
And every time they catch a
slave boat in the Atlantic,
they come with the
slaves and drop them
in-- the so-called
slave captives,
dropped them in Trinidad.
So the population of
Blacks in Trinidad
are created without
slave trades.
So the slave masters had
to take care of the slaves,
because they cannot produce
and buy all the slaves.
They must make sure that they
reproduce themselves locally.
Not only that, soon after
1838, the British stop slavery.
You see what I mean?
So the slavery
Haitians have known
for 100 centuries
with a slave trade
is not what the
Trinidadian has known, no?
And when you go
to Trinidad, they
are happy, happy going,
happy looking people.
They have never have problems.
They never fight.
They do not even
know how to fight,
because they never had to fight.
From the very
beginning, the masters
has to make sure that they
have a slave for tomorrow
at the beginning.
Then slavery become abolished.
So I tell them, you don't
know what slavery is.
You can imagine that.
Not only that, they start with
the indentured and flooding
the country with indentured,
so a whole other dynamic
and a-- whole
different sets of--
OK, this experience
in Trinidad now
then come and give
me the possibility
of seeing local
history developing
and how we are in
our local history
producing a way out of
quote unquote "our misery."
This is how I went and see the
importance of the language,
the importance of the community,
the importance of the higglers
because [INAUDIBLE],,
and I must say also,
the importance of the yard.
I have some strong
friends, Jamaican friends,
particularly Erna Brodber,
who wrote on yards.
That is-- and the way the
yard is important in Jamaica--
in Kingston she wrote that.
Me, I'm seeing the world
in the countryside.
Then you go to Dominica.
There are several
studies in Dominica
and Saint Lucia on the
family property system.
All of those are institutions
that are Caribbean.
It's not that you don't
have family property
system in France.
But it doesn't characterize
the land tenure system,
while in other countries
it is the basis
of land-tenure system.
And the work I have
used in Dominica
shows that those who put-- who
has land in the land tenure
system produce more
than those who have land
in the et cetera, et cetera.
So this is how I
end up in my why.
That's my why, because
I reach a point where
I can explain to myself
what they call poverty
and why we are quite
happy in that poverty,
if you want to see it that way.
We will be unhappy in the
city, because in the city,
we are not able to reproduce
the yard, properly,
to have our resources
to reproduce it.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK,
that's a good question.
[LAUGHTER]
JEAN CASIMIR: My why, [LAUGHS].
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yeah.
that's a good one.
JEAN CASIMIR: And
I had to answer it.
[LAUGHS]
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yes, you had to.
And you gave a beautiful answer.
So Jezhara?
STUDENT: So I guess
my question is--
JEAN CASIMIR: Remove your mask.
STUDENT: Oh, so
Creole languages are
very important to the
Caribbean community.
But we refer to English
Creole as broken English.
Or you promote French
over Haitian Creole.
So my question is,
what do you think
will happen to our
communities if we
keep rejecting that Creole?
STUDENT: I love this question.
JEAN CASIMIR: If you keep
projecting our Creole?
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
Rejecting, rejecting--
JEAN CASIMIR: Rejecting,
oh, it's that's suicidal.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: If
the state apparatus--
JEAN CASIMIR: But
first of all, let
me say that I have
an unproven theory.
And I'm trying to convince
some linguists to work on it
because I cannot.
But they do "la sourde oreille,"
they don't pay attention.
[LAUGHTER]
Forget about the English
Creole and French Creole,
because they are identified.
They exist.
They are bodies.
They have their syntaxes,
they have their vocabulary.
They have their words.
For instance, I don't go.
Mick, I see you.
You know what I mean?
These exist.
They are there to see.
My problems start when
I speak with the Puerto
Ricans and the Dominicans.
They speak Spanish.
[LAUGHTER]
They speak an imperial language.
Yet I'm pretty sure that this
imperial language carries
a historical tradition that
departs from the Castilian--
native Spanish from the
Castilian tradition,
you see what I mean?
And they must have
concept like we
have "whites,"
which is not white,
like "black" which is not black.
And this is what I call
a linguistic archaeology.
I want somebody to
tell me what the Puerto
Rican or the
Dominican or the Cuban
are producing that
define them and make them
different from the imperial--
STUDENT: Castilian--
JEAN CASIMIR: Going
from the Castilian.
You see what I mean?
OK, now in our case, the
problem, basic problem--
and this is a problem with
France and the French UNESCO
and so on, they have to
justify their existence.
They come with the
idea of "universality,"
the "universal" civilization,
"universal" God knows what.
And they want to
destroy all diversity.
And our elite buy into
that "universal" thing.
And they will tell
you, for instance,
if the Haitians speak Kreyòl,
they will be isolated.
I say, let's go quiet.
Haiti has now 8 to 12 million.
When I visited Curaçao,
they had 90 million, 90--
yeah, "quatre-vingt dix mille"--
90,000.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: 90,000.
JEAN CASIMIR: 90,000.
One day, I was
living in Trinidad.
And I wanted-- you know,
Trinidad is very strict,
quite British.
And you cannot buy everything.
IBM, everything is controlled.
So I'm going to Curaçao,
which is a commercial place.
I have to buy
something from IBM.
But I don't know where IBM is.
So I come on the street.
I saw a fellow well dressed.
He should know.
I ask, where is IBM?
He say, no, no, I don't know.
Ask that lady.
And the lady is selling fruits.
So I tell the lady, sorry,
excuse me, where is IBM?
In what language you
want the information?
[LAUGHS] The [INAUDIBLE]
from Curaçao,
she speaks to us a Papiamento.
But she speaks Dutch.
She speaks English.
She speaks French.
She speaks all
sorts of language.
I could choose the language
to receive my information.
Because in Curaçao,
as you would say,
Papiamento is taught by school.
They teach Papiamento
in the schools.
And the people speaking
Papiamento can speak--
learn and speak, because of
the commercial, any language
you want.
I mean, they are not
isolated by Papiamento.
Papiamento helps them to
be linked with the others.
So if we manage and control
our local languages, no?--
Jamaican, Haitians, Vincentians,
et cetera, et cetera, and we
can find out what is the
specificity of our language
together with other, we learn
to appreciate our language,
to appreciate their language,
and to appreciate us,
who have invented a way
of respecting everybody.
So to my mind,
this is the point.
And this is not a theory.
But I don't know how to call it.
They are when they
are putting down.
Or if Haiti speaks Kreyòl,
they will be isolated.
Aren't we isolated now?
And since when do
we speak French?
If France just learn
how to speak French--
they just learn.
It's 100 year.
I mean, French is---
I don't know, English
is worse, they told me.
And French is the language
of the administration
and of Paris.
And French was imposed on
the provinces of France
to strengthen the central power.
And it remains.
I mean, Eugen Weber
present that in his book,
"Le parler de terroirs"--.
It's really important,
because French is not
a country that come
from all French people,
because French was a
country of peasants.
And the plantation is the first
capitalist, rational economic
concern.
Now this is why when you
have English in Jamaica,
you have Creole English,
Jamaicans speak Creole English,
period, all Jamaicans, while in
France, you leave one village,
you go to another, and you
cannot understand what they are
saying, because they have
a small microclimate,
microvillage without this
connection that would give you
an internal comprehension.
This is a fact.
And when they say Haiti--
and then, well, let's
say Haiti speaks French.
From colonial times up to now.
Please, please.
[LAUGHS] Now it's-- they find
that insolent and insulting
that in some Canadian
and French University,
they request the Haitian
to present a kind of TOEFL
examination to prove
that this French.
And this is the fact.
I teach at university.
And there is university student
who really cannot express--
cannot present an
essay in proper French.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yep, yep.
STUDENT: It's also
interesting on top
of that about how they keep
that structure in French Canada,
despite even French Canadians
being treated as lesser
in the French eyes, because they
call Canadian French disgusting
French, like they
call it lesser French.
So it's funny how
even in Canada,
where it's like their
French is deemed lesser,
they still keep [INAUDIBLE].
JEAN CASIMIR: Yeah, because
they have the English also,
because they have the
English they think is better.
I mean--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So this is
really, really, really good.
So we've had an amazing
set of questions.
And I wanted to follow
up on Jazhara's question.
And here I want to go
back to the UNESCO issue,
because we heard this
very eloquent plea
from Ambassadeur Dominique
Dupuy asking UNESCO
on what grounds are
you classifying Creole
languages as lesser languages?
They are languages.
That's it.
But your work-- and one thing
which I love about your work
is that you show the beauty
and power of Haitian Creole.
You show the richness
of the vocabulary
and how the vocabulary can tell
us so much about our history.
And the fact that you put out
so beautifully words like "ras,"
"abitan," "moun," "nèg,"
"blan," "blanch," "milat"--
that all these words,
for them to have evolved
that semantics--
in fact, that's yet
another argument
against the idea
that Creoles
evolved from Pidgin,
because you see if Pidgin's
supposed to be like a tabula
rasa, like an empty
void of language
from which you create
a new language.
And your argument is that
no, look at all this richness
in the language.
So I want to stress that,
because often we still find
in various circles the
notion that Creoles
evolved from Pidgins.
And yet you've given us
through history yet another set
of arguments against that view.
And one thing I wanted
to ask you as well is--
so in your introduction
to your lecture on Monday,
you were introduced as a
historical sociologist, right?
But when I speak to you, I often
speak to you as a linguist,
you see?
What you tell me about Kreyòl,
about our national language,
you share all this data that
I as a linguist can so deeply
appreciate, you see?
So I want to ask
you, so why are you
being called a historical
sociologist when
in fact, so much of
your work is linguistic?
And here actually I'm playing
devil's advocate, right?
I don't want to say that you
should be one or the other.
I just I just want to hear
you talk about the role
that linguistics and language
make it even more explicit how
it plays into your work as a
sociologist and as a historian,
because I love it.
And I think that in
a way you give us
a model of how the human
sciences can really
operate together to discover our
humanity, our common humanity.
So that's-- and so I want
to praise you for that.
But I want you to say
something more about it.
JEAN CASIMIR: Let me
say that this idea come
from the group of friends
with whom I unite every year.
The Maria Lugones
Decolonial School, no?
It's a summer school
we have every year
during three weeks of--
three weeks, no--
in Holland organized
by the University
of Utrecht and Duke
University's Center
with Walter Mignolo.
And they do not
believe in disciplines.
This group is formed by
philosophers, historians,
economists, sociologists,
artists, of performers,
and all sorts of artists
and we are thinking.
And oh, I forget Catherine.
She's a sociologist
and activist.
But anyway, and this
group, no, they do not even
speak of "university."
They speak of "pluriversity."
You know what I mean?
I mean, this is-- we have
to save our plurality.
We have to save our
diversity, because this
is what I was saying,
the "universality"
that French and the
capitalist system want,
because they want one
"universal" civilization,
God knows what.
No, no, no, no, we will probably
have that "universal" thing.
I won't be there to look at it.
But when we all in our
diversity we contribute,
now we are negotiating
maybe a "university."
For the time being,
it's "pluriversity."
So therefore, you
raise the question,
how is Haiti so
quote unquote "poor?"
So I say, what is Haiti?
Well, the Haitians--
what is a Haitian?
For instance, De
Vastey says a Haitian
is anybody living in the country
having no other place to live.
So the Tainos are as Haitian
as all of those are Haitians.
OK, but if they
came from Africa one
by one, how come
they become Haitians
or whatever other
countries you have, no?
And you see what are the
institutions and the process.
And local history
become the heart
of the reflection,
local history.
I mean, by local
history, it's not
the local history you
find in the archives,
because in the archives you will
find the local history of those
who won the war.
So you have to see you people,
who is speaking, because you--
and to whom are you speaking?
You are speaking to your people.
You have to explain
to them what is it
that they have done themselves.
This is why I cannot accept that
the Caribbean will be British
Caribbean, French Caribbean,
Spanish Caribbean.
Come on, who are in the
Caribbean, therefore?
I mean, are we British?
Are we French?
No, no, we are Caribbean.
And we have made certain
number of things.
But not because we are
Caribbean we are all similar.
We have also a variety in that.
And this is for instance,
the real problem
when they say we are Blacks.
We are Blacks.
OK, "Black" is an invention
of the colonial world,
of the modern colonial world.
The modern colonial world
wants all of us to be the same,
so we can do whatever they want.
So for instance, the
richest Blacks among Blacks
will teach the other Blacks.
No, no, we all of
us have our values.
We all respect ourselves.
And we want to listen to you.
We want you to listen to us, no?
And out of this
variety of Blacks,
if you are to call them Blacks--
I don't call them
Black, but that's OK,
et cetera, et cetera.
And I think this is something
you have while you conquering
your sovereignty.
For instance, as far as I'm
concerned, Haiti's 1970--
1791 was able to
join together people
from different nations of
Africa and create Haiti.
But when you reach for
instance 2010, 2011 in the US,
you see all the oppressed
of the US come and say
"Black lives matter."
And when you look at
those who are saying that,
you have to make an effort
to find all the Blacks.
You find all the people
that are the most exploited
is the Black.
But you find all
sorts of Latins,
all sorts of Amerindians,
all sorts of whites
who have been exploited.
And they are "Black
lives matter."
And if this respect for
the life of the oppressed
become effective,
if you can impose
that on the dominant
system, I think many things
are going to change.
In fact, what you
have is the end
of an era, an era that is the
era where life does not matter,
period.
I mean, there is a wonderful
movie that just come out,
"Don't Look Up."
I don't [INAUDIBLE]----
that's a wonderful--
life does not
matter, simply not.
They have to make more money.
It's a nice movie.
It's sad, really.
It's sad, but it's comical.
I mean, it's cynic--
I don't know more than sad,
it's cynical, no more than--
you see what I mean?
This is the point.
We are saying "Black
lives matter."
We are saying life matters,
period, the life of the Earth,
the life of--
every life matters.
And if you can reach
that point, you
stop that system defined as
the producer of inequality.
I mean, this is the point,
because "Black" is simply
an element of inequality.
You can imagine that
fellow made a mistake.
And he called all
those Indigenous people
"all those Indians."
But that's his mistake.
Why should I carry
that mistake today
when I know it's a mistake?
This is worse.
This is the problem.
In Trinidad we call
East Indian etc. etc.
Well, why should
I say East Indian?
And we are supposed to be West
Indians, instead of mistakes,
eh, because West
Indian originally-- you
know it ends, no,
in the Philippines.
Everything that was from
the West was West Indians.
From us, America, way
down to Philippines,
that was the West Indian.
I mean, this mistake I
don't have to carry it
in the 21st century.
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
OK, so it's 2:57.
So we should think of closing.
I see that Merelin--
so can you make it--
JEAN CASIMIR: You
have a question?
STUDENT: Yes.
So like this whole
idea, it's like, how
do we have this conversation--
how do we have this conversation
outside of the classroom?
And if Black and race
is a social construct--
JEAN CASIMIR: I don't get you.
Come again.
STUDENT: Oh, like how do we have
these types of conversations
outside of the classroom,
because we are having it.
And it's a difficult
conversation.
And also, like if "Black" and
"race" are a social construct,
then what are we supposed
to identify with,
especially like in a
country where Americans, we
like to categorize things?
So it's like, what do we do?
Like for me, I struggle.
I struggle a lot
to say what I am.
Like, I am Dominican.
I am Caribbean.
But like in the US, they
do focus a lot on race.
So it's like, what
are we supposed to--
JEAN CASIMIR: No,
I cannot tell you.
What I can tell you is that
it's a matter of local history.
In Haiti, we end up
creating the Haitians.
In Jamaica, we end up
creating the Jamaicans.
In Haiti or in Jamaica or in
any country of the Caribbean,
Blacks are the majority, no?
Then I will tell you about
the Dominican [INAUDIBLE]
is something that
I am the only one
to accept, not the
Dominicans, not the Haitians.
Make me remember that.
The problem is local history.
Blacks in the US
are 1 out of 10.
In Haiti we are 99 out of 100
or in most Caribbean countries.
So Black is what exists.
So you cannot say--
one day I told a friend
in Haiti, you say,
"Black is beautiful," you know
what they're going to tell you?
"Is there anything else?"
[LAUGHTER]
Because we are all Black.
How do I need not
to be beautiful?
[APPLAUSE] [LAUGHTER]
MICHEL DEGRAFF: It's to-- end
of that term you have to--
JEAN CASIMIR: You
have to finish?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: --has
to close, right, Tom?
Yes.
So--
JEAN CASIMIR: No, I
haven't finished me.
[LAUGHTER]
But
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK, so, so good.
JEAN CASIMIR: Let
me try to do me.
So I think this is
where the local history.
I can understand the US
African-American ending up
identifying himself as
"Black," because this
is what unites them, that
held their local history.
That is not our local history.
And I can tell you,
I suffer for that.
But because I went one day and
say something about Blacks.
I say, well, in Haiti,
Blacks, that's not an issue.
Oh boy, imagine.
OK, that's one thing.
So the problem is
to see how "Black"
appears in a given context.
Now, for my Dominican
Republic problems--
the Dominican Republic say
"Black-- that's in Haiti.
I'm not Black.
I'm a dark Indian, not a Black."
Obviously this is
scandalous for those
who are not Dominican Republic,
except Jean Casimir, because I
say, listen, go to Dominica,
the island of Dominica,
an island which has received a
large part of land as a reserve
where the Amerindians
or the Dominicans lives
and they reproduce themselves.
In their society since colonial
time, men who make a kid with--
I mean, they are Indians.
They are-- ah,
not Tainos, Carib.
Men who have an offspring
with a Black woman, the kid
is Amerindian he's carrying.
Women of the Caribs who make
a kid with a Black outside,
the kid is Black.
So you can imagine you cannot
distinguish between Black and--
because if you living in
the Carib among the Caribs,
you're a Carib, and
et cetera, et cetera.
If you are in Dominican
Republic, you are Ladino,
or you are a slave bought
by Christopher Columbus,
and you get in
marronage, you go and you
are received in an Indian--
an Indian, ha, Taino
community, you have a kid,
the kid is going to be Black.
He's to be Taino, period.
He's not Black, no
matter how the color is,
and so on and so forth.
Now if you are receiving
Blacks in Haiti
and they will come
in the DR, they
are Blacks, because they are
not born in an Indian society.
You see what I mean?
So I find normal
that the Indians
say the Haitians are Black.
They are not Black.
They are Indians, dark
Indian, but they are Indians,
because this is the population.
Now Christopher-- not
Christopher Columbus.
Ha, yeah, that's a good slip.
Rafael Leonidas Trujillo--
now we'll use [LAUGHS] that
as the slip-- will use that
to make of the Black something
different and to discriminate
against the Haitians and also
to discriminate
against the Black--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Dominicans.
JEAN CASIMIR: --Dominicans,
because et cetera, et cetera.
But I am not supposed to
carry the sin of Chris--
Mr. Rafael Leonidas
Trujillo, the same way
I don't want to carry
the sin of Columbus, no?
So I have to acknowledge the
normal Dominican is right.
"Black" is Haitian.
He is not that... well--
But nobody accept that.
[LAUGHS]
MICHEL DEGRAFF: But
didn't you say--
was that you also
may have mentioned,
but it's a whole discussion that
there's no time to get into,
that in Haiti, there
is colorism, right?
JEAN CASIMIR: Obviously.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: That's
mixed with class.
So there's that famous
saying of Jean-Jacques Accau
that a rich black is a
mulatto and a poor mulatto
is black, right?
JEAN CASIMIR: No, no, providing
he knows how to read and write.
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
Exactly, exactly,
so anyway, so that's a--
JEAN CASIMIR: Whole other story.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: We
have no time for that.
So let's be extremely,
extremely thankful
and I'd like to give a
big round of applause
to Professor Jean Casimir.
[APPLAUSE]
JEAN CASIMIR: That was nice.
That was nice.
I applaud to you
for your questions.
It was nice to meet you.
Thank you very much.